c'était au lendemain de noël il y a
pratiquement un an la france était
balayée par la tempête du siècle de
mémoire d'homme jamais catastrophe
naturelle d'une telle ampleur ne s'était
abattue sur le pays 88 morts et des
dizaines de milliards de francs de
dégâts à villemoisson dans l'essonne
silva le kent et stéphane taponier ont
retrouvé une famille est sinistré par
l'ouragan une famille qui prépare noël
après avoir passé une année
particulièrement difficile
l'immeuble est à ciel ouvert le jour de
la tempête le toit de leur appartement
cet angle
ça c'était la toiture créé était au sol
le lendemain matin un an après les
images sont encore présentes la famille
le roux en garde un souvenir douloureux
7h15 on a entendu un fracas des verts se
sont brisées dans la vitrine
l'immeuble a tremblé
un constat
que l'immeuble septembre et ça va on a
cru que notre dernière heure était
arrivée comme il est la seule solution
c'était de se rapprocher les uns des
autres donc on sait tous on s'est tous
rassemblés
après la tempête les oeufs rouen vendu
leur appartement pour acheter ce
pavillon même si les proches ont t d
ainsi que la fondation de france qui
leur a versé 15 mille francs l'année a
été difficile
ce trait démarches administratives
les conséquences que ça eu sur la vie de
tous les jours les conséquences
familiales les conséquences
professionnelles
en fait que cette année passée à une
vitesse phénoménale
aujourd'hui ils préparent leur réveillon
avec un peu plus de sérénité un premier
réveillon après la tempête qui se fera
dans l'intimité a prévu peut passer tous
les quatre ensemble on a besoin d'être
un pur de se réunir et de livres 1 après
noël sera avec les enfants comme une
ombre à leur joie ils jouent avec et qui
en profite et
c'est vrai que c'est important
un an après ce réveillon symbolise une
étape même si les stigmates de la
tempête ne sont pas d'oubli fera pas les
mauvais souvenirs mais peut-être un
nouveau départ
pour passer sur 7
sur ce thème à prendre